boa tarde meu nome é rajesh é e pra
falar de carreira eu gosto de começar
com a seguinte pergunta que é o que você
faz da vida que provavelmente uma
pergunta que a gente ouve ouviu muitas
vezes e ainda vai ouvir muito nessa vida
porque quer que seja na primeira
oportunidade profissional quando a gente
já conhecia alguém num bar por exemplo
ou mesmo os aplicativos de
relacionamento a chance dessa pergunta
aparecer logo nas primeiras conversas é
muito grande e não é toa que ela aparece
constantemente essa pergunta porque de
fato a a resposta dessa pergunta é que
não tenha grande parte da nossa vida o
que a gente faz da vida e se a gente
pára pra pensar que a gente começa a se
preparar para o mercado de trabalho com
aproximadamente 18 anos
a gente se aposenta por volta dos 65 70
são quase 50 anos da nossa vida que a
gente vive em função da carreira e hoje
muito menos do que falar de profissões
do futuro ou falar de qualquer a
carreira mais promissora que vocês podem
escolher eu tô aqui pra falar de quais
são essas novas possibilidades de
carreira qualquer nova dimensão que a
carreira ganhou já que o mundo assim
como a gente viu o toque anterior ele
mudou é o conceito de carreira também
mudou então é importante entender
algumas mudanças no mundo quando a gente
olha para esse mundo muito mais volátil
um certo complexo e ambíguo é importante
ver que alguns fatores na sociedade
mudaram significativamente então quando
a gente olha que o poder de várias
questões o foco estava antigamente na
posse ter um apartamento ou ter um carro
era muito mais importante do que hoje a
experiência mobilidade por exemplo a
gente vai pra um processo também de ééé
centralização para compartilhamento e
acho que as redes sociais refletem muito
esse movimento que a gente vive hoje do
compartilhamento constante de ser humano
de seres humanos e apesar de que alguns
podem questionar tem também um movimento
muito grande
do individual para o coletivo então
claramente o mundo mudou e
consequentemente as carreiras também
mudaram eo que humildemente quero trazer
um pouco da minha visão de carreira
tendo passado por uma transição de
carreira bastante significativa e tendo
ajudado mais de 200 300 pessoas
ao longo da minha trajetória a
encontrarem caminhos de carreira que
faça mais sentido é eu trago para vocês
um pouco de alguns elementos que eu
entendi ao longo dessa trajetória que
são importantes para entender o conceito
de carreira do jeito que ela é
então o primeiro conceito que eu trago é
profissão
a maioria de nós tem uma profissão que
está muito associada a uma formação é e
o grande perigo é quando a gente deixa
de ser o raj
a dani o joão e passeios simplesmente o
economista a publicitária o
administrador no momento que a profissão
sequestra nossas identidades e se torna
um perigo isso aconteceu comigo quando
eu tive a oportunidade e um privilégio
bastante grande de me formar numa das
melhores faculdades nos estados unidos a
economia fazer uma imersão também o
curso de verão na london school of
economics em londres
quando eu saí receber o diploma é eu
percebi que eu era apenas um economista
eu acreditei muito daquilo eu deixei que
o mundo contasse que eu era apenas um
economista e foi isso que aconteceu
quando comecei a fazer a entrevista de
emprego as pessoas falavam você tem um
perfil quantitativo você é puxar é muito
mais bem finanças e foi o que aconteceu
eu fui trabalhar no empreendimento de
consumo na área de finanças e nada
contra os planetas ou financeiros mas
odiava as planilhas odiava olhar aqueles
números o java não fazia parte de mim
não era parte de quem eu era então é
muito importante quando a gente olha
para a carreira
entendo que o primeiro elemento
profissão
ele é determinante mas ele não pode
seqüestrar a essência ea identidade de
quem a gente ama e aí eu continuo uma
jornada em busca de um significado maior
com correlação que era carreira e me
deparo com o segundo elemento que a
busca do propósito e pra mim é um dos
essenciais fundamentais quando a gente
fala de carreira a olhar propósito
propósito e antes de entrar na história
dessa imagem é uma pessoa que foi
influente na mim no meu encontro ao
propósito foi o economista muhammad
yunus não se vocês conhecem ele autor do
banqueiro dos pobres o livro branco dos
pronomes pobres e também ganhador do
prêmio
o rapaz quando eu li é a metodologia de
abordagem de que era possível sim você
criar mecanismos que ajudasse as pessoas
a quebrar a barreira da pobreza a
quebrar fronteiras aquilo se conectou
muito com a minha realidade porque é eu
acreditava que era possível trazer um
conceito de finanças incorporar o
incorporá lo para uma casa maior e
cruzar fronteiras coisa contra não só
econômicas sociais mais geográficas
sempre fez parte do meu dna é e de quem
eu sou
só para você ter uma ideia é essa a
cidade imaginar onde eu cresci na
fronteira do cidade de leste com o
código azul eu usava todos os dias essa
fronteira em busca de uma educação
melhor do paraguai pra fazer o assunto e
ouvia também milhares de pessoas que
cruzavam a fronteira em busca de
oportunidades uma vida melhor condições
comprar recursos comprar produtos em
países revendê los em outro e eu percebi
que essa questão de cruzar fronteiras se
tornou quase que uma obsessão da minha
vida é pra mim aquilo se tornou a grande
missão da minha vida e não só cruzar
fronteiras mas ajudar as pessoas a
cruzar fronteiras porque eu percebi que
lá estava não só na minha infância no
meu crescimento
mas também no meu dna porque quando olho
pra história é dos meus ancestrais meu
avô que saiu do paquistão pra ir pra
entre por causa da separação dos dois
países
o meu pai quando com 18 anos teve que
sair da índia para ir para lá tentar a
vida ou minha mãe que é colombiana e
cruzava a fronteira com o paraguai para
comprar produtos e revendê-los a
colômbia e ainda quando eles conheceram
no patamar uma dessas jornadas e foram
para o paraguai com 700 dólares no bolso
a idéia de cruzar fronteiras sempre foi
uma opção e faz parte da minha história
então esse encontro com o propósito
quando me deparo de novo é com a
possibilidade de fazer essa mudança das
essas pessoas pois o que foi sentido pra
mim então eu decidi trabalhar com micro
finanças em 2007 e nessa jornada foi
muito interessante porque é quase que
uma identidade foi seqüestrado de novo
porque quando fui fazer o processo
seletivo as pessoas falaram os rh dos
entrevistadores falaram pra mim
você tem perfil de banco de investimento
você funciona muito bem banco de atacado
eu falei não eu quero pra heliópolis e
paraisópolis brasilândia eu quero pra
comunidade eu quero conhecer o interior
desse brasilzão e falei se não for isso
não é nada e só não tem a vaga então a
gente não vai ter a oferecer essa
oportunidade eu falei tá bom
eles abriram a vaga pra mim que
microfinanças então é essa questão da do
propósito ter muita certeza do que eu
tinha é fez com que é eu não deixasse
ser cegado por influências externas
e aí como é que também e no banco isso
acontecer um banco é um lugar que o
terceiro elemento que eu trago sobre
carreira é muito importante que o
elemento de dinheiro é impossível não
falar de carreira se a gente não fala da
nossa relação com o dinheiro e da nossa
relação com as finanças
eu sempre tive uma relação muito linear
com o dinheiro que ela era crescente pra
cima e sempre e em 2009
me deparei com os maiores dilemas da
minha vida porque eu recebi uma bolsa de
200 mil dólares se a gente converter em
reais é muito 0 são muitos zeros
é pra fazer um mba no exterior do banco
e ao mesmo tempo uma consultoria de
microfinanças é que tinha operações na
áfrica e acessou e fez uma proposta já
tem uma proposta pra você e oprah
madagascar oprah tanzânia ou para a
libéria o brasão biopav gerem a lei e
até sentir vergonha porque nem saber
localizar esse país no mapa é eu
pesquisei um pouco rapidamente eu falei
tá bom se for nigéria ou libera ou não
vou porque é muito perigoso e arriscado
se focando os três eu vou e passar para
a próxima fase do processo seletivo e a
estatística jogo completamente contra
mim e foi libéria nigéria e aí eu
poderei nigéria de um lado um pouco mais
desenvolvido mais bastante violento e de
um outro lado tinha questão da libéria
que é um país pós guerra se recuperando
a guerra civil com infraestrutura muito
precária o país com maior incidência de
malária no mundo eu falei poderei se for
libéria não vou de jeito nenhum e
proporcional libéria
a lei como economista achei que tinha
uma chance ainda de fugir mas não tive e
os 26 anos para a loucura da minha
família e alguns amigos
eu larguei essa bolsa de bebê de 200 mil
dólares e fui pra áfrica ea áfrica
embarcar a jornada é de microfinanças
viver o meu propósito e também foi um
momento que eu desconstruir a minha
relação linear com dinheiro e quando
você diz constrói essa relação de linear
com as finanças com a remuneração se
pode ter muitas surpresas positivas
conforme os dois anos seguintes que eu
me surpreendi assumir uma equipe de mais
de 100 pessoas na áfrica foi de uma
operação interna de um país é de micro
crédito mas também quando você assume
essa opção não linear você tem várias
surpresas também porque é graças a essa
relação não linear com dinheiro que você
permite experimentar várias coisas
porque em 2011 quando decidiu largar o
mundo das microfinanças que já vou falar
pra vocês é nas jornadas que a mim me
aventurei é foi onde foi justamente
abordar experimentar várias outras
coisas como ser consultor de rh
treinador recrutador designers serviços
pesquisador é educador professor aluno
de psicologia então essa não é essa
experiência só se deu graças a não
linearidade que eu tive com relação ao
dinheiro
então é uma coisa que eu sempre aprendi
na minha vida é o que eu me questionei o
dinheiro é objetivo consequência e tudo
bem em alguns momentos da nossa vida o
dinheiro ele for é o objetivo mas é
importante que a gente saiba que se ele
for objetivo provavelmente a gente abre
mão de várias possibilidades várias
experiências
então a gente falou de profissão
propósito e dinheiro e um quarto
elemento me remete um podia ser
diferente a áfrica a libéria monróvia
capital da libéria
o lugar é um lugar onde você vai
experimentar a sua carreira lugar
lugares e eu não falo só de lugar
geográfico mas os lugares as culturas
que você vai experimentar as empresas
você vai trabalhar os contextos nos
quais você vai ter inserido e o lugar
pra mim faz muito sentido porque a
libéria ao mesmo tempo que abrir mão de
um ambiente é possivelmente nos estados
unidos ou na europa
eu sinto que eu fiz um ambiente mais
poderoso que podia ter feito com relação
a pessoas ea vida porque eu tenho
certeza e olhando
atrás que na libéria foi um lugar onde
fui mais triste mas mais feliz
a libéria foi o único lugar que
conseguiu colocar no lugar de
vulnerabilidade e vulnerabilidade quando
falo é ter energia elétrica no
apartamento 12 horas por dia é morar num
apartamento que estava infestado por
ratos e baratas é é não saber qual seria
o futuro do país e é nesse lugar de
vulnerabilidade ou de incerteza que a
gente se conecta com o que realmente
importa com a nossa essência com quem a
gente é que os lugares que a gente vai
estar
é importante a gente entender
compreender que a gente tem que estar
conectado com a essência se conectar com
a essência é extremamente importante
então nesse processo e áfrica faz muito
sentido pra mim e eu fiquei a idéia é
ficar seis meses acabei ficando dois
anos na áfrica entre libéria e tanzânia
acontece algo muito curioso porque eu me
convence a ficar
o microcrédito na áfrica e continuar
fazendo o que fazia pelo significado
pela conexão com propósito eu via muito
significado daquilo que eu fazia
mas mesmo assim eu não continuo tendo
prazer eu não gostava ainda de planilha
de excel não não consegui gostar de
planilha de excel
não gostava de dar de taxa de
inadimplência não gostava de falar da
taxa de juro não gostava de falar de
produto financeiro eu falei faça o que
tem significado tem impacto na vida das
pessoas estão trabalhando operação de
microcrédito que dá acesso ao portal
para a vida das pessoas mas não gostava
daquilo e curiosamente um terço do meu
tempo era dedicado a treinamento e
desenvolvimento dos agentes de crédito
que vinham com um background um
histórico de educação bastante precário
e eu me apaixonei por aquilo trabalhar
com educação capacitação e
desenvolvimento de pessoas
foi uma coleção muito especial pra mim
ea partir daquele momento quando
encontrei a questão do prazer no
trabalho é algo muito poderoso porque eu
comecei a levar trabalho para casa eu
comecei a viajar
graças ao trabalho e quando você
encontra prazer no trabalho você percebe
que a fronteira do que é trabalho e do
que não é trabalho se dilui ele ele
passa uma vida só você vive uma vida em
função da sua carreira então encontrar
esse prazer
foi o que foi o meu
amado não só para continuar trabalhando
com a educação e desenvolvimento mas
fazer uma transição completa mente de
números para pessoas que foi que eu fiz
quando voltei ao brasil depois da áfrica
para trabalhar com educação e
desenvolvimento humano é aqui no brasil
e é eu acho que tão importante quanto
esses outros cinco elementos é e talvez
um dos essenciais e fundamentais são as
pessoas com quem você vai encontrar na
sua carreira e quando falo de pessoas
eu lembro de vários mentores falando pra
mim é que é importante que você trabalha
com pessoas é que agreguem pessoas que
você admira pessoas que sejam
inteligentes e isso faz sentido pra mim
foi bastante sentido pra mim na minha
trajetória na minha história
só que eu comecei a entender que tinha
um passo a mais
trabalhar com pessoas que você tem uma
capacidade enorme de construir relações
de intimidade intimidade mesmo a gente
sabe que quando a gente olha para os
nossos relacionamentos construídos
umidade não é uma tarefa fácil nas
relações que a gente vive nas relações
bastante liquidez que a gente tem na
sociedade mas todas as vezes que eu tive
intimidade no trabalho foram foi quando
encontrei os lugares mais poderosos com
relação à criação construção e fazer a
diferença na vida das pessoas e quando
você constrói esse lugar de intimidade
você acessa não só o seu melhor lugar
mas também o melhor lugar da outra
pessoa e quando você encontra o melhor
lugar de outra pessoa você acaba levando
um pouco daquela pessoa para a sua vida
e para a sua trajetória
então estes seis elementos começaram a
fazer parte do conceito do que eu falo
que hoje a carreira pessoas prazer
propósito o dinheiro o lugar que a gente
vai morar e seis elementos quando a
gente olha para alguns deles é e eu
acredito é muito difícil você tem que
ter mais do que alguns poucos propósitos
são algumas coisas que nos causa um
prazer mas a gente pode se deparar com
mais de sete bilhões de pessoas nesse
mundo quando a gente fala de carreira
a gente pode fazer uma profissão que
talvez nem foi criada ainda a gente
assim como morei em monróvia na libéria
em dar es salam na tanzânia a gente pode
morrer em qualquer cidade do mundo e
quando a gente vê essa conexão a
possibilidade estatística essa conexão é
exponencial
então o conceito de carreira muda quando
a gente percebe essa lógica
ela pode ser uma combinação de muitas
coisas e hoje quando as pessoas me
perguntam o que eu faço na vida eu
decidi não falar mais que eu sou
economista e consultor de rh que o
trabalho com desenvolvimento humano
a resposta eu tenho falado é que eu sou
um inovador para um mundo sem fronteiras
porque eu percebi que a carreira não é
uma questão de escolhas falar de
carreira
hoje a gente como indivíduos como a
sociedade muito mais do que nunca a
gente tem o poder e ea liberdade de
criar a nossa carreira e eu encorajo
cada um de vocês
a busca dessa jornada a criarem a
carreira de vocês é uma jornada que vale
muito a pena
obrigado
[Aplausos]